des canards quelques pêcheurs et
beaucoup de calme ce lac est pourtant
niché au coeur de senonches petite ville
d'environ 3000 habitants qui surprend le
visiteur par le nombre de ses bâtiments
classés monuments historiques comme la
mairie l'église et surtout le château
cette tour porsche est l'un des seuls
vestiges de l'édifice médiéval qui a
servi de frontière entre la france et la
normandie il y avait des châteaux
une première vigne de château est arrivé
9e et une troisième avec châteauneuf et
ce nom ce qui était là pour s'opposer à
l'intrusion anglaise passé de seigneurs
en seigneurs au fil des siècles ce
château a aussi fait l'objet d'une
bataille judiciaire cette fois afin d'en
récupérer la propriété mais pas
seulement il restait une tour c'est tout
ce qui restait alors pourquoi se bat
pour une ruine car une on s'en fichait
complètement ce qui était important
c'est que vous avez une forêt et la
forêt céder sous fait qu'on gagne de
l'argent
le château qui abrite aujourd'hui un
musée consacré à la forêt se trouve à
quelques pas de l'un des plus vastes
massifs forestiers de france mylène
animatrice emmène d'ailleurs un groupe
d'enfants découvrir ce patrimoine
naturel
on a de très beaux arbres évidemment pia
les grandes en fait la plus grande forêt
du département vingt quatre mille trois
cents hectares de forêt domaniale donc
public c'est notre fierté puis puis on
en prend soin quoi c'est notre c'est
important du coup que les enfants et
connaissent le 6 ce milieu là c'est leur
environnement c'est là c'est un super
terrain de jeu la forêt les enfants
apprennent ainsi à jouer dans la forêt
mais aussi avec en faisant résonner les
branches et bruisser les feuilles